you welcome to Hannity tonight if you
are over the mass hysteria if you're
over politicizing and weaponizing of the
corona virus you are not alone that's
why tonight we're focused on two major
stories first we're going to call out
anyone and everyone who's using this
virus as a political weapon against the
president SiC it's sad but predictable
I'm sure in the end the mob and the
media well they will be advancing their
new conspiracy theory and their newest
hoax probably they'll come up with
hypothetically I'm just guessing
wouldn't shock me
president Trump Putin mad scientist's
and Russia Ukraine are manufacturing the
coronavirus on purpose so they could
hurt innocent children and kill Grandma
and Grandpa before they throw them over
a cliff before they feed them dog food
look it is time all seriousness for
simple fundamental truths to protect our
fellow Americans have means Democrats
Emmys Republicans liberals conservatives
and libertarians and everybody in
between viruses do not have a political
identity so tonight we will separate
cold hard truths when what is the mobs
latest manufactured irresponsible
over-the-top rhetoric or medical 18 and
dr. Austin I will explain Plus coming up
we will show you how Democrats and the
media now want you to ignore real
concerns about quid pro quo Joe and as a
parent and is increasing inability to
complete thoughts and deliver a cogent
speech it is now a serious campaign
issue by the way with serious Democrats
when Ronald Reagan was running for
re-election we have the evidence but we
start with the media mobs ongoing effort
to now use a virus an infectious disease
as a political weapon all to bludgeon
President Trump
yet again I've said many times if he
cured cancer they would likely want to
impeach him for curing cancer
now the corona virus is a serious
disease now should you and your family
be concerned of course you should be
concerned about the flu you should be
concerned about a cold you should be
concerned about any health risk should
you be informed absolutely we all need
to take necessary precaution Reese Tepes
yes all of us but the coverage we are
seeing from the media in the mob is
beyond despicable and political for
example Sunday you got Chuckie Todd
boasting the coronavirus
I could actually help President Trump
like the Iran hostage situation hurt
Jimmy Carter Washington Post editorial
calling it president Trump's Chernobyl
and over there at state-run conspiracy
TV MS DNC poor liberal Morning Joe
saying Trump's stupidity will cause
Americans to die I meanwhile joyless
read well actually telling her viewers
that the children of Trump supporters
were more likely to spread the
coronavirus to other kids just made that
up I guess that's what they do
lies the conspiracy theories the
psychotic anti Trump rage well it's been
non-stop sadly this is all we've gotten
for three plus years
take a look what is the government
really for the government is there to
protect you from terrorism for a health
thing just exactly this thing this is
exactly the function of government and
our government is growing up this may be
Donald Trump's Katrina this is an event
that could take down a president what
the Iran hostage crisis was the final
year of Carter's presidency not his
fault but it's it's a test in real time
the president is doing nothing but but
playing in his political sandbox while
this virus continues to spread silently
across America all right these people
sound like they really care about the
country protecting human life or they
just looking for any and every way
possible to bash President Trump last
week's New York Times editorial spelled
it out pretty clearly they named a
coronavirus the Trump virus and they
wrote if you're feeling awful you know
who to blame it's getting close to that
lab conspiracy theory I was kind of
joking about that's how sick it is now
this kind of coverage has serious
ramifications why people panic chaos
ensues recently group of shoppers caught
on tape what are they doing they were
brawling or they brawling over the last
pack of toilet paper now we've also
witnessed a recent market sell-off
although today's drop likely had a lot
more to do with an oil supply battle
between the Russians and the Saudis than
anything Corona related but markets are
skittish let's cut through all the
hysteria and all the BS let's give you
some simple truth and facts here's the
Surgeon General of the United State
to America you don't believe dr. Hannity
let's listen to him I'm not a doctor
people over the age of 60 they're much
more likely to develop complications
from the corona virus and to be
hospitalized from the corona virus the
average age of death is age 80 now what
we also want communities to know is that
if you are a child or young adult you
are much more you more likely to die
from the flu if you get it then you
ought to die from corona virus so there
is something about being young that is
protective we want people to be
reassured by that we want people to know
that we are really focusing in on those
those groups that are at highest risk
for complications
just to recap according to the Surgeon
General of the United States people over
60 their most at risk for corona related
complications or hospitalization now the
average age of mortality is 80 young
people unlike h1n1 that tend to impact
younger kids more than older people but
now in this case older people are much
more likely to die from this from
regular flu actually then coronavirus
believe it or not
and remember despite earlier reports the
likely mortality rate could be as low as
1% doctor foul she was out there in the
New England Journal in the first few
hundred cases of corona in China he
wrote quote there were no cases in
children younger than the age of 15
either children are less likely to
become infected or their symptoms were
so mild that their infection escaped
detection by the way as an older person
I'd rather be on me let's be honest here
kids have their whole lives ahead of
them and it's important to remember this
administration took unprecedented steps
on the corona virus seriously and a lot
of criticism to boot the no president
ever cept Ahnold trump ever acted faster
ever acted sooner or have done more to
stop the spread of an infectious disease
keep in mind the virus was not
officially detected and named until
January 7th H o recognized it on
December 30th 30 in the last year that's
pretty quick and on January 31st the
president declared a public health
emergency and he's the one that ordered
the travel ban and quarantine which we
hadn't done in decades and by the way he
did it again
the advice of many by the way that were
offering him advice out of an abundance
of caution
that's the travel ban to China that's
when that began three weeks later
quid pro quo Joe Biden others called the
president for doing this this band was
xenophobic fake News CNN suggesting the
president is stigmatizing people from
other countries and for the better part
of February
now what were the Democrats do oh that's
right they hardly address the virus at
all they were too busy and too focused
on impeaching the president over nothing
now they see more interested in scoring
what is nothing but cheap political
points then actually working with the
administration to protect our American
family well we want to protect every
American life here today the president
asked for lawmakers help them with a
payroll tax cut to ease Korona related
economic concerns that is really gonna
help and be impactful to small business
hourly wage workers etc around the
country well hopefully the Democrats
will come to the table and do what's
right for America
well they alleviate the economic fallout
of Corona or will they do nothing to
continue to use it as a political weapon
politicizing a disease again coronavirus
is a serious matter it's not the end of
days sadly pandemics like this happen
more often than any of us would like
h1n1 worldwide killed over about a half
a million people according to estimates
the US has the best doctors by the way
h1n1 we lost nearly 14,000 Americans we
have the best doctors the best
researchers the best scientists anyone
in anywhere in the world and the Trump
administration will continue to
aggressively stop the spread of this
infectious disease we also forget people
that get flu every year some years tens
of thousands of people die from the flu
every year people die from the flu now
should we be smart wise learn things
how'd it be neat clean not yeah of
course let's protect our families but
let's do it a thoughtful way